and back in the the car of the smash hit
stay did you and Charlie know each other
Billy because of queer as folk days and
you're a big pop star you'd have thought
you'd be not all the same showbiz bashes
I can't remember you I mean that's a my
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
used to watch your inquiries for all the
time and Russell T Davies roses so right
yeah but I can't remember anything from
those because in my head I thought queer
as folk was your big break
but in fact it was before that wasn't it
oh it was indeed it was indeed the old
illustrious Byker Grove but you you
weren't an actor you just showed up Mike
your growth yes pretty much I was I had
the aspirations to be an actor I was a
AB storm school at that point but I was
discovered in a shoe shop on the thumb
beer story - JD sports on Christmas Eve
I had a foolproof strategy with my
Christmas shopping I would go to the pub
on Christmas Eve at 12:00
and a for one hour before the shops shut
I would start my Christmas shopping and
I had the 60-minute frenzy chop this is
good and I was in JD Sports trying on
some trainers for my brother having a
bit of a dance around drunk obviously
and and there was a lady staring at me
and so I blew her curse and gave her a
little wink and it turned out she was
the production manager of Byker Grove so
she said I think you're quite lovely
she invited me in and I did an audition
and they gave me a part which I haven't
seen since I did it which is 20 years
ago and now I think you're probably
gonna humiliate because I mean you are
excellent as King Arthur but that it was
all here it was all here it's slightly
raw for me so this this is it's a very
traumatic scene
you think shoot an out of an and debt
with a paintball gun because they were
long gone
that was Harold Eckert long this is you
you're doing I'm blind
[Laughter]
singing nestlé's to get out of school I
did this is a strange I think it's a
strange e adult
storyline for for Byker Grove you play a
model and I think you're initiating a
younger boy into the ways of being a my
God look right now running straight dead
smile what's that cheese and scallion
don't one it's a finger buffet upstairs
man all right well it's just you know my
girlfriend made them first
it's all a done in this game all we have
to do is look good and cash the checks
don't worry May I'll soon start yelling
[Applause]
are you at all
don't be nervous now I'm still the same
old Charlie I've never heard a finger
buffet sound so rude beautiful thing
upstairs
would you cast him off I have to tell
you I only wish I could have derived
such a performance job you're sexy when
you were young Charlie
[Music]
you